[Musique]
3 pts 2
dimanche éperdument nouveau spectacle de
lionel hoche et sa compagnie mais mes
banjo depuis début décembre ils sont en
résidence de création au théâtre du
président à elancourt accompagnés par la
mission danse de saint quentin en
yvelines
une oeuvre musicale en trois parties et
qui mêle trois personnages sur scène
dans un environnement l'avenir et c'est
une petite épopée d'une via un duo d'un
côté puis un personnage un peu un peu
fantomatique de l'autre qui reflète
peut-être un peu un état du monde qui
ressemble étrangement à ce qu'on vit une
manière très métaphorique et onirique et
puis soudainement on arrive dans un
univers très coloré qui est l'endroit de
tous les possibles
dans dimanche éperdument beaucoup de
chansons en live avec de répertoire de
standards de jazz assez connu
[Musique]
il est pas réservé à une élite ou à une
façon de comprendre l'art contemporain
c'est un endroit qui accueille tout et
chacun est l'idée c'est de vraiment de
se laisser emporter par cette part cette
vision des choses par ces personnages
qui sont là et par ce monde un peu
étrange mystérieux prévue pour le 15
janvier la date de représentation a été
repoussée à mai 2021
si les conditions sanitaires et les
décisions gouvernementales le permettent